movies they're an illusion literally a
magic trick still frames projected on
the screen to trick the eye into seeing
movement and life that's true that we
make the movie in production but we
sculpt the movie in the editing room
where real magic happens by cutting
those frames together on a precise order
that creates an emotional impact and
tells a story since 1934 the academy has
recognized the women and the men whose
skill for combining distinct images has
elevated the art of moviemaking there is
now my honor to present this year's
nominees for achievement in film editing
baby driver Paul matchless and Jonathan
Amos Dunkirk Lee Smith
I Tanya Tatyana s regal
[Applause]
the shape of water Sydney will in ski
three billboards outside editing
Missouri John Gregory and the Oscar goes
to Dunkirk Lee Smith
[Applause]
this is the first
third nomination for lease Smith he was
previously nominated in this category
for the Dark Knight and master in
command
[Applause]
[Applause]
I just want I just want to say this is
the most awesome thing that can happen
to a guy like me I really want to just
start by thanking Christopher Nolan who
they moved me from over there to sit
with him because Chris is an editor
himself I mean he doesn't handle the
actual equipment and I'm very very happy
for that his fabulous wife Emma always
supportive great producer incredible I
mean Dunkirk was truly the most amazing
film and I'm very fortunate to have
worked on it I'd also like to thank my
beautiful wife sitting over there
Kimberly my daughter up in the nosebleed
section
wherever my I'm wrapping up I'm wrapping
up Melanie Bram Sir John Lee my
editorial assistants Warner Brothers the
Academy can't talk any quicker
I'm an editor I should be able to do
this very quickly Matthew McConaughey
awesome thank you